so I thought it'd be cool to to play one
of these
and play with Zen mode
where I won't know any of my poems
ratings
looks like I'll be doing rapid but oh we
might see a comeback few seconds 18 to
20. oh wow it's gonna be close 21 all
wow it's a tie
what's the tie breaker
I guess I'll play I'll play The Blitz
tournament because that was my vote
okay so I'm Lee joining the hourly Blitz
I won't know who I'm playing
and to make it extra spicy
I'm gonna play a Gambit every game
here we go okay I have no idea who I'm
playing
I could be playing a strong player or a
complete beginner
but we'll see how this goes
I do promise to playing at it
G4
what gamut can I play against G4
this is what Carlson was playing the
other day
I play F5
okay this is my Gambit
F5 might be the worst possible move
against G4
but the idea is to win back the pawn and
accelerate development
okay so this is very groblike Queen B3
is intention
I'll play again
[Music]
okay I'm gonna go a little bit crazier
this is intentional
I'm allowing Bishop takes Rook
because
I want to get rid of whites only
developes
after it takes takes white will have
nothing
developed
oh wow so I have this move
it's kind of risky though
I'm realizing that there was takes and
then Queen H5
I have this move
this is getting really spicy
yeah there's still oh there's still some
issues here
seven
oh no
I have to go for this
[Music]
young children close your eyes fans go
wild also quack
it's actually kind of cool I'm gonna
lose the Rook
and so far this game white has declined
taking my Rooks but
okay the queen is Reborn
materialize I'm down the full Rook but
I'm threading wait can I have this and
this
is why losing a queen
no I my Bishop's pinned
I have this move oh no I have the
dreaded spicy cough
um
okay I'm trying to figure out what to do
here I want to play this
I think this is okay
idea Queen D3
what a position
all of White's pieces have not moved yet
including the queen because the queen
was just born on the square
it has yet to make a move in this game
until Queen C3
okay so now I have Knight D3
I also have Bishop G7
also have this Rook lift idea I also
have this move
so many possibilities
and queen D5
looks natural
I have to keep in mind to guess the ELO
too
uh
uh it's hard to say like I'm I'm
probably objectively worse here
but I'm also
maybe having chances
because white didn't take the Rook
earlier I'd say below 2000
okay now I can take him in the bishop or
check him in the bishop
there's Queen D3
how to do this
thinking this move actually
oh there's a crazy line
but it involves trading Queens which I
don't necessarily want
a G2 doesn't work
I'm playing this move I'm trying to keep
as much tension as possible
eventually bring the rook in
Manny White is so underdeveloped here
yeah welcome to everyone joining
uh this is the first game in the Stream
definitely not the last hopefully not
the last
this Knight is basically tied down to
defending the queen
except the opponent proved me wrong but
now I win the queen
okay life is good
I I gotta guess like maybe 1600 maybe
1500
um
I'd probably say 1600.
hopefully I can finish this off
where's my meat
play this move
idea of Knight H3 okay let's see
2300
I feel bad for under guessing
2300 what a funny game
I mean I was confused that they didn't
take the Rook but I guess this E4 is
logical
also in in this position
there's there's takes in Queen H5
okay uh one of the start to the
tournament let's move on
I played wait does that opening have a
name
G4 F5
the alessi Gambit it has a name wow
probably named after Mr Gambit
or Mrs Gambit
okay uh 25th Place
playing again in Zen mode
so for those unaware of Zen mode I don't
know my opponent
I don't know their rating
all I know is
it's chess and
I'm gonna try and play as fast as
possible but also as fun as possible I'm
playing an ortho snapcambit
the point of the orthostop is to get a
more open position
[Music]
black is declining taking the pawn which
is playable
now takes upon and yeah generally the
point is to get this battery against F7
that's already like kind of tricky for
black I'm thinking out with another Pawn
allowing takes with check because I just
want to accelerate development
I want to get the Rooks for the center
and we have another position where
oh oh D2 I have to take with King we
have another position where black hasn't
really developed most of the pieces
uh I think this move
I mean maybe Knight F3 first
now let's play this first
I mean the e-file is completely open
[Music]
I do have this move
I'm calculating Bishop D4 because B7 I
take on F7
the promise C5 comes so I think I'll
play King C1
and yeah there's various directions of
attack
there's also the prospect of Knight E5
wow
hmm
there's a funny line
but how do I make it work
I'm thinking take on F7 I want to play
this move with Chuck
also take on A7 with Chuck any bishop
move his check
um
Bishop C5
yeah let's play Bishop C5
and then I'll take
and now I'm winning material
okay this game I'm I'm also guessing
like 15 or 1600
I'd say like mid 1500s
please don't tell me my opponent's like
2300 again
uh
the abbach black fell victims of a
activity in the position
I mean to be fair it was a difficult
position to play out of the opening
okay threatening threatening these sort
of things lights pinned so
want to add attackers
now it's no longer pinned
but I'm up a piece I'll play this move
I mean a lot of pressure points
I'll start with this move
aligning with the King threading this
wow
I mean I could take the Rook but I'll
take first with Chuck
and King is kind of tied down to the
knights
ties have been broken
okay uh
1555 let's see
1924. wow I feel so bad I'm I'm under
guessing completely
uh
I guess like the gamuts are just too
powerful though
was playing in such a style Maybe
provokes my opponents to blunder more
okay my next guess I'll guess like
realistically and then I'll just
subtract 400 points
or I know I'll add 400 points
uh I I have to offset my guesses because
I'm clearly under guessing oh my sun
moon
okay I mean I saw the I saw the
opponents so
um I'll leave it in Zen mode uh just so
I don't
um
don't see the next opponent
so this is actually called the nozzle
was Gambit
there is a pre-move trick like some
players in bullet will pre-move E6
but it's also a Gambit because I am
allowing Bishop takes pong
and the point of this I mean if Bishop
takes one I would have played D5
so this is essentially a nozzle was
declined
I think I still want to treat this as a
Gambit I'm allowing Pawn Jake's Pawn
and the point is I'll play Pawn D5
just grab space and cut off the bishop
some idea Bishop B5
with quick development
okay aligning with the queen
there's Queen B4
and pawn D4 is not playable
Knight takes E4 Queen B4 check
there's also Knight B5 which is
interesting
I was met with Knight A6
I mean I think I'll start with Bishop B5
check just develop with tempo
and the queen looks very tropical here
Pawn C6
where's my trickery
I could take the knights
I don't think that really leads to much
I could play this and this
maybe I'll take first
just maintain the bishop
no need to overthink this
I think you i-007d
I want to use the D file
and Rook d8's coming
Knight D2 doesn't work
okay I have a cool idea actually Queen
D5
it seems counter-intuitive to trade
Queens
when I'm down material
currently down the pond
but after it takes takes in Knight C7 is
the threat
so maybe it's Justified
wow upon E6
so I could take
I think I'll take the queen and win back
the pawn
I'll maintain some initiative
targeting the bishop
and this is kind of a positional threat
why no music
because there's cases when I stream
where I want to post the video to
YouTube
and I don't want to get copyright struck
so
if you want to listen to music you can
open a new tab but you've been my
favorite educational and bedtime content
for two years thank you for all the
gambits the wholesome jokes the funny
lines and calm Vibes also for rekindling
my love of Chess also you bring value to
so many people
also
quack
that's so sad I got cut off
there is a character limit to TTS but
I appreciate the words cyclist boy
that was a very nice message
okay what's happening here I'm down a
little bit of time
but
I got the bishop here
and looks like I'm gonna
I mean assuming we trade like Bishop F3
Bishop A7
I have three connected pass Pawns
on the queen side
black has a four on two majority
but I mean the pawns combined with the
bishop hair
should be really nice here
I'm also somehow up a pawn
which I don't exactly know how that
happened
I was down upon earlier
okay let's start pushing
yeah maybe the bishop should have gone
to C5
and if F4 Bishop C5 or Bishop D4
Hit The Rook first
I don't mind that The Bishop's aligned
the knight's kind of restricted by this
bishop
now keep pushing
I mean it's a sharp position because VOC
has a lot of storm potential
my King has no legal moves
but it's not easy for the Knight to
migrate to H3
okay so now this is actually an idea I
have to be careful
uh maybe this move
hitting the pawn
wow
okay so now The Bishop's hit
yeah I'm not sure which ELO I would
guess for this opponent
I think my opponent's playing like
around 1700 strength
like at some point mishandled things
maybe didn't make any like super obvious
blunders although G3 was a nice gift
okay I'll take with a rook
foreign
's probably rated around 17 alone
Got The Accidental Peak earlier
um
and this looks very strong
as if Rook D3 Pawn A7 and the King moves
I have Rook C7 check and then queening
the vengeful meat
okay now I'm just trying to find my
Force mates
uh check
and this should be simple enough
where's my mates
I want to play Bishop E1 Rook H4 mate
I don't think there's any stopping guns
black could give up both Rooks
but it's not quite stalemate because of
the epon
there's that move to
okay I'll take and make a queen
thank you to gulu02
okay so just to show yeah
um
1701 I'm still playing the same opponent
so Zen mode should be on for the next
game
so far I'm three out of three
we had the Alaska Gambit against the
grab we had the orthostnop Gambit
and then what was that last one
I was white
what was the opening of that last game
I don't even oh there was a nozzle loss
yeah the nozzle was declined it was a
strange one
okay new opponents
opponent taking time
I mean I'll go for a staffer if white
allows it
I have no idea who I'm playing usually I
like if I'm going to play a Tavern I
like to know who I'm playing to kind of
gauge how prepared they might be
I like the fact that white took a little
bit of time there
and it's taking a little bit of time
here to
[Music]
pawn pawn E5 is one of the better moves
against weaker players I like to play
Knight E4 against stronger players I
play Knight D5
Bishop E2 interesting
I'll do this about five
so I'm down the pond and
usually the plan for black after Knight
D5 is to get some like longer term
compensation
usually go for a sharper position like
if like castles King side then all
Castle Queen side
there's already this idea too
ignite B4 Knight A3
there's a really funny line 93 982
Rook A2 Queen D5
let's say Rook goes back Queen G2
there's Bishop F3 unfortunately
considering C5 and some of these lines
I'm just pressuring the pawn
hey welcome back to Jerome Gambit please
okay next game
maybe next game depending if my opponent
allows it
okay so I have
three attackers against D4
if D5 I just take on E5
we might expect Bishop E3 and then I can
take and maybe get the other Bishop in
I might take away White's Crossing
rights
for the time being D4 is still well
defended
foreign
[Music]
but probably the best move
not sure what to do though I'm
considering Queen H4
I think I'll play Queen H4
I feel like this is the most flexible
move
these are cases where I would just want
to play Rook T8 and Target d-pong
also pin the d-pawn like Rook d8 would
threaten to take on E5 Maybe
thank you to Honey Ham
it's C2 is a move
that does allow takes and takes
I lose C7 at some point
there's Queen C4 actually which might be
deadly
foreign
with the bishop Knight Queen and
eventually Rook
I think it makes sense to take I mean
even Queen side Castle
[Music]
and this attacks both Pawns
although I'm not sure if I'm actually
threading this because Queen F5
and D4 is defended three times now wow
Queen F5 here I have Rook D7
okay so Queen H3
well now I have Queen H3 preventing
Queen L5 and then Knights
takes Pawn
I think this is okay
and there's Queen B5
the very least I have Knight C6
at the very most I have some like crazy
checkmates
still kind of far away from me though
Queen B5 I probably play Queen H5
it's actually looking really nice I'm
also realizing uh Queen B5 of Queen G4
Queen E4
hitting various things
okay let's start with Queen G4
actually realizing white took a lot of
times of liking F1
and King F1 was the only move
which makes me think the rating is less
than two thousand
I'd maybe guess like eighteen hundred
I'm threatening made in one here
why you played an interesting opening
definitely above average player
maybe like 1850
I've been so bad with guessing today
watch it be like 2400.
maybe I should say 1900.
such a feel-good position
so I'm no longer down the pond
pieces are
fully optimized I could take the
what's the best way to do this I'll take
this first
foreign
G2 Rooks do not like to be feeding
cattle
because they're just blocked by Pawns
Eric D2 is an idea
my goal is to meet before White flags
oh where's my meat
gee
I want to play G4 checkmate
where's my mate
oh there's a funny mate
Rook H4 checkmate
is not checkmate
okay let's see 1900 1900.
1669 okay I over guessed
at least I don't feel as bad over
guessing compared to on your guessing
good game to rookie move
I think I recognize that name
oh wow
if I want to win this tournament I I
might have to start berserking
oops okay I didn't see the name
um
forgot to turn back on Zen mode
uh
all berserk this might be a risk but I'm
gonna I'm gonna try and win the turn up
on the berserking back
okay I'm gonna go for Halloween
happy Halloween
I feel like I'm playing a strong player
c6s maybe some Theory
although D5 I thought is the most
theoretical move
so Halloween Gambit it's um it's a very
seasonal opening
I'm down a piece but there's some
interesting forms of compensation
that's a good move
I might slow play this a little bit
Guardian Knight G3
sometimes it's just a matter of getting
long-term compensation
wow what a move
okay black has one piece developed on
each or
G6 is very wise
I really want to Sock more
you see four
Bishop B3 first
idea this this and eventually casting
I gotta defend though
king of wanna
change the plans
foreign
this is going to very quickly turn into
a bullet time scramble
gotta preserve my time can I take that
that's just a trade though
that five yeah
holding on to my Bishop
there's some idea to play G4
I'm not sure if I can make it work
wow king of fate
takes ticks
I'm still just down a piece but such a
closed position that extra piece for
that doesn't mean so much
like right away
um black is clearly a good player though
foreign
space
in all directions
wow the knights trapped I didn't even
realize that just accidentally trapped
the Knight
this night is almost trapped too
because I'm mating
okay now somehow I'm up a piece
I went from being down a piece to up
abuse
trick or treat
happy Halloween
oh no my Rook
Oh no you're Queen
that was very poetic and the opponent
had to be like over 2 000 maybe like
2300 let's see
okay 22 20. I didn't see the rating of
the opponent I'm it's back in Zen mode
um okay still undefeated
first place lost their first game so
gives me some local coming back
I will berserk the next game
oh I still have to play a Jerome for
the request from earlier
oh and thank you Onyx a dog happy 10
months
how do you do Zen mode
um
the simple way is to press Z
but you can also change it in your
settings okay England Gaba time
uh let's play this in D6
E4 is a fine move
this is actually what the nepo zombie
bot played against me recently
in this zombie speedrun
play this
I'm trying to like
to figure out if this that playing with
Zen mode is actually like changing the
way I play because sometimes I do judge
all right I I do like
have my opponent's rating affect my
playing style
like sometimes I'll I'll be Reckless if
I'm playing someone much lower rated but
I always have to assume my opponent is
like a strong player
and I have to play a little bit more
controlled even though I'm playing a lot
of like Ultra aggressive dubious gambits
so I went back the pawn I have some
damage structure but
I don't think it's so bad
the queen 97 Castle
and we'll probably see this in this
I might wind up with
another set of double Pawns
yeah we're getting some end game
almost looks like white can win upon
yeah Knight E5 I can't defend C6
oppon's not biting though
foreign let's play this
actually wait
annoying move
[Music]
let's play this
I'm I'm in some trouble here
but how bad is this 985 Rook eat Rook to
G4
there's actually a funny trap
I will say if 95 earlier I had Bishop B4
so I was hoping my phone would play that
that's a good move
yeah I feel stuck
I have this move rookie six
kind of holding on
yeah it's not a fun position
always played Bishop f8
thank you
I'm still holding on though
like C5
really ugly move
but it opens up defense of um this Pawn
maybe I'll bring the king in
White's played a good game so far like
really has done nothing wrong
foreign
Place somehow
[Music]
play this
good move
I'd love to trade off the bishop even if
I do lose a pawn
oh that's a great move too
I'm getting completely ground down
foreign
foreign
s
soon to be three Pawns
okay I have my Alpha zero Pawn
not sure if that will save me
let's play the really good game
just a little bit slow though
some counter play
foreign
there we go okay
oh
all the safe
what's my phone's reading it's got to be
like 2400. hey 20 23.50 let's see
oh 23.50 let's go 23.42
back to tournament
I held on
uh yes uh that player is
a little bit behind me in standings
okay less than six minutes left
man what a game
I won't play really well that game until
until still meeting me
okay
I'll play D4 here
this is a so-called bruinstein Cabot
when you combine the Queen's Pawn with a
grab
opponent does not seem phased by this
there's a funny idea to lift The Rook
it's probably really dubious but
I mean I just want to use the G file I
can double on the G file too
the benefits of not having a g-pawn
okay I'm playing a four pawns attack
so this Rook just migrated to G3
and we might see Bishop H4
don't think I would mind that though
they punish for
pushing all my pawns so early
uh I don't want to trade let's play B B3
smiling
okay
this is a cool position I have a lot of
space
and black is still pretty solid though
that should stalemate trap be worth 10
tournament or tournament or tournament
points it's so satisfying I was very sad
and warm greetings from Liverpool Eric
you think that's true
I think I can take here
and if takes I take it gets really
tricky though I might just be winning a
piece
that's a fork
I mean there's some crazy queen queen of
six Bishop D4
I mean it's actually kind of crazy
I guess Queen F6 I have 94.
this is looking nice still have plenty
of time
I've moved all my pawns so far
I don't know what move number it is
because Zen mode also hides notation
yeah this was probably gonna crumble
really quickly for luck because there's
a lot of holes on the king side
okay I'm guessing 1900.
2100
tactico
okay there's time for one more game
I'm in second place it's not possible
for me to
overtake first
I'll try and make the next game count
for the tournament
I might play the person in first place
although I guess I won't know until
after the game
no the first place is playing that
though pairings are closed okay well
that's the tournament for me
dough I got passed
by a person from the country of leeches
anyway that was a fun tournament
um it's not officially over
hopefully I can maintain my
third place standing
third place
that was fun
I hope people enjoy that
was fun to combine Gambit and Zen mode
and guess ELO
so the average rating of my opponents
was over two thousand
my average ELO guess I think was under
two thousand like my first couple
opponents I had guessed in like 15 1600s
okay so if I put this on YouTube
uh shout out to everyone watching in the
future on YouTube
don't forget to subscribe it does help
the channel and
my goal for for YouTube is to hit 600
000 subscribers before the end of the
year
so thanks for watching and stay tuned
for more content